when you start a company you always have
to be very very convinced that you have
a unique idea that has the mileage only
we Bernhard my business partner is a
six-time Iron Man winner and he hooked
up with a Swiss engineer to completely
reinvent the running shoes when you look
at the outsole off beyond you see these
elements we call them cloud you slide
into you run very slowly but then for
the push-off they collapse so you have a
solid surface to push off from sorry our
biggest challenge was to get the
credibility so that people really
believe that on is something different
so we actually printed t-shirts that say
don't ask me about the shoes when we
were at fairs we almost forced people to
try to shoot it before we told them
anything about the technology
the first word that we were always heard
and still hearing today is wow that's
different
when you're a Swiss company you have
this very small market if you want to be
big in running you have to go to the US
and we are now at 300 of the best
specialty running retailers they have
been doubling tripling even quadrupling
their yearly sales with all we try to be
a very lean and agile company we do
technology and technology development
ourselves but then we have outsourced
manufacturing you also have outsourced
the full logistics chain logistics
warehousing
we don't touch the product from the
factory to the end customer
the running market is a huge market it's
more than 15 billion worldwide we can
still grow tremendously so it's all
about widening our base in this core
specialty running segment and then
penetrating and making our dealers
successful